and they're they're calling this guy
schizophrenic they're saying he has
mental issues all he's there to do is
get his son and this is why a lot of men
just stop fighting because imagine
having to do this once a week imagine if
you want to see your kid on Sundays
every Sunday you got
to go up and get your
son deal with this a lot of men walk
away from situations like this because
they just don't want to deal with it and
messages dated January 15th 2022 dar
allegedly tells his mother hey Mom Kiki
turned off my phone if she tries to get
you in trouble you have these pictures
to prove your innocence take all the
pictures because she is the celebrity on
a separate occasion an alleged exchange
between the pair reveals Kiki
apologizing I'm sorry for hitting you
I'm sorry for being afraid to lose you
and that turning into me acting out of
fear and
Desperation wow